My sister has been staying at her house for a few weeks now
and she usually does not have a preference on what we eat
as long as it's vegetarian,
but today she told me she was craving potato gnocchi,
so I obviously had to make her some right away.
I baked my potato until soft,
grated my tomatoes, chopped up some onions,
sliced up some garlic.
I sauteed my onion with some basil until it was soft,
added in my garlic, and let that go for a couple more minutes
before adding in my grated tomato.
I seasoned with some salt, pepper,
Italian seasoning, let that simmer while I mashed up my potato.
I made sure there were no clumps,
and then it was time to get my gnocchi going.
I combined some flour with the potatoes,
some eggs, salt,
and as soon as it came together,
lucky needed it until it was smooth.
Once it came together, I cut it into smaller pieces to roll out.
I rolled out my dough into little ropes
before cutting it into bite size pieces
and transferring it over to a flowered baking tray.
I let them boil for about a minute or two
until they floated to the top,
toss them in my sauce, and they were done.
This dish is so simple but so good.
I top it with a bunch of Parmesan cheese and it's absolutely divine.